each year microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world
including leading scientists renowned
experts in technology
book authors and leading academics and
makes videos of these lectures freely
available
okay so today we're very pleased to have
chris pikert visiting us
um to speak about lattice-based
cryptography
chris is coming to us from sri he did
his phd with sylvia mccauley at mit
and he's doing lots of exciting work on
lattice-based cryptography and lossy
trapdoor functions and lots of other fun
things so
thank you chris thank you thank you
kristen and uh thank you everyone for
coming
um before i start i was warned that uh
kristen
asks a lot of questions so i want to
encourage everyone else to do the same
and
we'll make it interactive so
the topic for the talk is lattice-based
cryptography
and in modern cryptography over the past
few decades we've had
some enormous successes in this
discipline
we can do some amazing and seemingly
impossible
things for example we can run an
election where every voter
can be assured that her vote counts in
the final tally and yet nobody can
convince anyone of how they voted we can
query a database
without revealing to the database
anything about what we're actually
looking for
and a group of mutually untrustworthy
parties untrusting and untrustworthy
parties
can play a game of virtual poker over
the internet without
needing to employ any kind of trusted
trusted dealer or anything like that
so all of these applications build upon
a rich
set of fundamental cryptographic
primitives such as encryption for
confidentiality
digital signatures zero knowledge and
other protocols
and all this is is built uh rests upon a
foundation
of mathematical problems fundamental
mathematical problems that we believe to
be
hard or intractable although we haven't
been able to find proofs
of these conjectures yet now
looking at the breadth and depth of all
the applications and
primitives that we have the foundations
to me maybe or
maybe to you also might look a little
bit narrow essentially all the schemes
that are in common use today rely upon
one of two
assumptions either that factoring the
very large numbers is intractable or
infeasible
or that solving discrete log the
discrete logarithm problem
over certain kinds of multiplicative
groups is hard
and many schemes rely on even stronger
assumptions than these
but as a baseline they at least all need
one of these two problems
to be uh to be hard
so let's let's take a little bit closer
look at factoring based schemes
a typical typical operation in these
schemes is what's called modular
exponentiation
or exponentiation modulus some large
number n that's the product of two
primes
concretely it looks something like this
we take some enormous number
we raise it to the power of some other
enormous number and then we take the
remainder
uh when divided by some other enormous
number n
so these numbers look pretty big but in
fact this is a toy example
uh the real numbers that you would use
in practice are about two to five times
longer
not two to five times as large but two
to five times longer as many digits
okay now in many cases this presents no
problem we have good algorithms
for performing these operations but in a
lot of scenarios with restricted devices
or in high throughput scenarios the cost
of doing this a lot can become
prohibitive and the reason is we have to
use such
large numbers because we need the number
n to be hard to
factor now
speaking of hard to factor there's also
kind of an uncomfortable fact that was
and very surprising fact that was
discovered by
peter shaw in 1994 which is that
factoring is actually easy for quantum
computers
so more precisely shore gave an
efficient algorithm that works in the
model of quantum computation
that will take in any number n and uh
schrodinger's count will run on it for a
while and spit out the two factors or
however many factors there are
and and i checked that that is an
accurate uh factorization
so did you try with a random
component you just took it backwards
yeah i i
used my home quantum computer yeah uh so
so this is this is slightly
uncomfortable because uh if we don't
have quantum computers yet
but um if we even think that there's a
moderate chance or even a small chance
that quantum computers might be built in
a large scale
then essentially all the crypto that we
use today
at least commonly used will be
completely insecure i should mention
sure's algorithm also works for just
for the discrete log problem over any
group so there's no saving us there
either
so if we're worried even a little bit
about
quantum computers even in the far future
we should start thinking today
about what are some alternative
mathematical foundations
what i'll tell you about today is what i
believe a very promising avenue
for in that direction and
it's based on objects called lattices
which are
geometric objects that are seemingly
very simple but actually extremely rich
that were studied by very stern-faced
looking mathematicians for about 200
years including gauss
blickfeld hermet minkowski and many
others
and schemes based on lattices have a
host of potential advantages first
is that asymptotically they're actually
very efficient this is because their
operations are very simple
typically involving just linear
operations like multiplication addition
uh with very with reasonably small
integers
this is this is about the kinds of sizes
that we'd be encountering moreover these
operations
are trivially parallelizable so notice
you know down these columns we have all
the same
numbers and on modern architectures
where there's a lot of inbuilt
parallelism both multi-core
and within cores there's very easy
uh these can be these operations can be
accelerated
very quickly lattice space
a lot of space schemes also seem appear
to be very secure
in particular we don't know of any
quantum attacks
shore's algorithm doesn't work for
lattices and despite a lot of research
in this area
there's basically we don't know how to
speed up things using a quantum computer
at all
moreover they have a very interesting uh
and unique
security property uh unique in
cryptography
of what i'll call hardest case or worst
case security
this was first shown in this pioneering
work very beautiful work by itai
in 1996. i'll speak more about what this
what this means a little bit later but
basically in the decade following itai's
work there were many improvements
extensions simplifications
but in terms of cryptography not a whole
lot changed
so pretty much only all we knew how to
do
was a couple primitives called
cryptographic hashing
and uh public key encryption uh in in
all this this
long line of works for the first how to
decade yes
hashing that's a big problem okay
so we could do something called uh
collision resistant hashing at least
to be precise uh
so in this first decade not a whole lot
changed from a cryptographic point of
view
what i'd like to tell you about today is
that actually lattices oh
this keeps jumping lattices and a lot of
space schemes can be extremely
expressive
very rich we can get lots of strong
primitives
that allow us to build rich applications
so this will be the outline of the talk
first i'll go into some detail about a
line of works
that i've been doing with various
co-authors
that follow the theme of how to use a
short basis in a cryptographic scheme
this is based on work uh with gentry and
vaikuntanathan that appeared in stock
last year
which introduced several new techniques
and some new cryptographic instructions
and then i'll talk a bit more about some
further applications that we built
the first two works appeared in crypto
last year the w is waters
and and then also there's an upcoming
work in
this stock with additional applications
and i believe there'll be many more
in the future then i'll talk a bit more
generally about some related threads
of research that i've been doing and
some problems that i hope to tackle
uh in the future the talk will be
extremely informal i won't give anything
resembling uh
remotely resembling a proof but the nice
thing about lattice-based crypto is we
can draw lots of pretty pictures
so we'll be seeing a lot of those um so
now is a good time to pause and
take any questions you might have or
concerns
anything like that before i move in
here what are some of the other you
kind of applications us a hint that
there's more than passionate encryption
out there
okay so uh i will actually say so in in
the very next slide a couple of those
applications
um actually there's a long history of
using lattices in cryptanalysis
um in breaking uh sort of what are
called knapsack based
uh crypto systems back that were
proposed back in the 80s
what i'm talking about today is a
complete reverse side of this which is
to use
hard lattice problems as a foundation
for secure schemes rather than rather
than breaking them
so i won't say anything about uh the
sort of traditional application of
lattices and crypto although that's
that's a very rich
rich area as well
okay let's uh sorry
like quantum algorithms or the
reductions from
something that couldn't support problems
yes uh i'm
i'm not an expert on this most of the
reductions go in the
uninteresting direction as far as i'm
aware
so they say that if you could solve
what's called the dihedral hidden
subgroup problem then you could solve
certain lattice problems uh but but that
doesn't tell us much because dihedral
subgroup
hidden subgroup is is the sort of famous
open problem for quantum computing
so uh i believe i have the direction
right i don't think there are any really
interesting completeness results for
quantum
okay so let's plunge ahead so part one
how to use a short basis
example primitive uh that the mirror
asked for uh
is uh digital signatures so this will be
a primitive to keep in mind as we go
along
and the idea behind digital signatures
is we have these two people alice and
bob
who would like to maintain a
relationship over the network they're
about to be separated
but they want to make sure that they're
talking to each other so
what they'll do is alice will create two
related keys she'll create a secret key
which she keeps to herself
and she'll create a related public key
which she can post on a bulletin board
or give to bob directly
before she heads off and when she wants
to send bob a message over the network
in the future
she takes that message and applies some
algorithm together with her secret key
to attach uh to compute and attach a
signature
to the end of the message which then bob
can use her public key
to verify that the message is
authentically coming from alice
and the security property of digital
signatures roughly is that
after watching many signatures go by uh
an interloper shouldn't be able to
create a message and and forge a
signature from alice so
this this black hat will never be able
to convince bob that
he's alice so that's roughly the
security property we're looking for
one of the main tools especially in
practice for building digital signatures
is something called a trapdoor function
so the idea is the public key will
be a function or a description of some
function f
and the secret key will be some trapdoor
information that gives us some power
some extra power about f concretely
this proposal uh the the earliest uh
proposal was given by diffie and hellman
in their seminal paper over three
decades ago they proposed what was
called a trap what they called a chapter
permutation
this is a bijection from a domain onto
itself
and given the description of f you can
easily compute in the forward direction
but given a random point in the domain
it should be hard to compute the unique
pre-image
of that point without knowing the trap
door of course if you know the trapdoor
then it's easy to go in both directions
okay
so it's pretty easy and very natural to
imagine how
we can use this kind of primitive if we
have one oh by the way i should mention
different hellman uh articulated this
concept
and then a year later uh the famous rsa
system which was proposed by robes
schemer and edelman
there have been a few other proposals
since then but they all rely on the
hardness of factoring
so once we have this object we can then
construct a very natural hash and sign
what's called a hash and sign signature
scheme
and it works roughly as follows if alice
has some message she wants to sign then
she hashes it down
to a point in the domain and we imagine
this hash function is some kind of
idealized
uh random function and that gives us a
point y
which we can which alice can then invert
using the trapdoor and that will be the
signature
bob can of course check the signature by
simply applying f to the signature and
checking that it equals the hash
of the message and roughly this seems to
be hard to
forge because if we want to forge a new
message then we have to be
able to invert some random point in the
domain
i'm being informal here but that's
roughly how it works
so what we'll do in this work is
introduce a new twist on this very old
and
cherished concept and it's what we call
a pre-image sampleable function
so we're changing the picture a little
bit we now have
uh domain and range which are not
necessarily the same
in particular the domain might be much
larger than the range
and furthermore we endow the domain with
some probability distribution
may not be uniform however under this
input distribution
f maps to the uniform distribution over
the range
okay so if we pick an x randomly from
the input distribution
we'll get a uniformly random output in
the uh
range okay so the property as before is
it's easy to compute in the forward
direction
now notice that because the domain is
much bigger than the range
just by a pigeonhole argument there are
typically going to be many
inputs that map to the same output y
the security property is that for a
random value y we shouldn't be able to
find any
of these pre-images
with the trapdoor we can we can indeed
invert but what we require is something
a little bit stronger instead of just
being able to find some pre-image of y
we want to actually sample from among
all the pre-images
under the appropriate distribution that
is under the can
the input distribution conditioned on uh
it being a pre-image of y this is where
we get the name pre-image sampleable
okay so what this requires is some kind
of
algorithm some kind of algorithmic
innovation that allows us to pick
from all the pre-images with the
appropriate distribution
okay okay so that's the concept
now we can imagine what if we did hash
and sine uh what if we follow the hash
and sign
approach for signatures so again it's
the exact same thing
we hash the message down to some point
in the range
and then we apply the pre-image sampler
to pick out one of the pre-images a
random pre-image which will be the
signature
now it turns out that this scheme is
just as secure
as the previous one that i showed you
that was based on trapdoor permutations
the reason is is not obvious i think but
it turns out that the crux of the proof
the security proof is that we can
generate a pair
x and y in two equivalent ways with the
same
joint distribution okay so what happens
in the real system is
a y is chosen uniformly from the range
and then we sample a random pre-image
what happens roughly in the proof is
that we choose an x from the input
distribution
and then it go in the forward direction
to a uniform point in the range
and if you look at the joint
distribution of the this pair
it's the same in both pictures
you think about that this is some kind
of
um simulated yes experiment
on the one side is the reality on the
other side
what so what is the challenge that you
want uh so
embedding the challenge is is uh is
essentially how
the same way that it works in in the
previous schemes what i'm talking about
here is just how you simulate
access to the signer that's the signing
algorithm
so you can do it by computing x in the
uh
computing in the forward direction and
and then you know a signature
x for any hashed value you make
so actually we're we're modeling this
function h as a random article
which is sort of unfortunate from a
theoretical point of view
although it's what typically is used in
practice it's basically the only
practical signature schemes that we know
of
so with the caveat that h is random as a
random modeled as a random oracle
which is what we need also in the case
of trapdoor permutations
we get the same security result
okay in fact i've i've slightly uh
undermined myself in fact the proof
because of this
because of this uh many pre-images
property
the proof and embedding the challenge is
actually uh simpler and tighter
than the ones we have for trapdoor
permutations
so we can actually give a tight security
reduction from our signature scheme
to the security of the pre-image
sampleable function
and these type reductions are not
possible when you're using trapdoor
permutations so in a sense
this is actually a better primitive for
uh for the security proof
which is somewhat surprising
i guess just to drill down a little bit
further
the using the random oracle model
suggests that
in particular even if i'm giving one
pre-order
that's correct that's right that is an
assumption that's part of the course
uh it's not an explicit assumption but
it's guaranteed to us by the fact that
it's a random oracle
yeah so so finding uh two
inputs to random oracle that collide is
going to be hard uh of course
meeting that notion constructing a true
random oracle is a very challenging open
problem
what i want what i want to stress here
is that we're playing the same game
uh security game as we normally play in
practice practice oriented
signature schemes so just to
make sure i understand that what you're
saying is that if you use a
tractor function in in and
you have you give the attacker the
additional ability to query some
pre-images
yes random points in the range
not equal to the one challenge that you
might give that's right adversary then
it doesn't affect their ability to solve
each other that's correct exactly right
and the reason is precisely because we
have these two
uh you know that getting random
pre-images of random values y
can be simulated by going in the forward
direction here
and the important point is that the view
of the adversary is the same in both
cases because the joint distribution on
x and y
is the same which is why we need this
pre-image sample ability
property it wouldn't be enough to simply
pick some canonical pre-image
and every time we need this random
sampling
any other questions about this this is
this is the abstract primitive that
we'll build
and uh one of the applications i'll talk
about a few more later
okay so all that's left to do is build
it which
is maybe the hard part um so we're going
to build it based on
of these objects i've been talking about
called lattices
and a lattice is simply a periodic grid
of points
in n-dimensional space r to the n
euclidean space
one way to define it is as the set of
all integer combinations of some
n linearly independent vectors so here
we have b1 and b2
coming from the origin and the green
points are all the points in the lattice
going to infinity
any given lattice in two dimensions or
more has
an infinite number of bases so this is
one basis
which looks pretty nice this is another
basis which doesn't look as nice
in particular the vectors are longer
they're more skewed
you now have the integers z which are
infinite that's correct
previously you had to introduce mod 257
like much better
because that's right that's right so the
actual scheme is that it use a finite or
yes yes so the actual scheme is going to
use
a finite ring z mod 257 or some prime
something like this
the foundation the the cryptographic or
complexity foundation will be arbitrary
lattices which go off to infinity but it
is
it is kind of interesting that we can
take it from this
unbounded world to this bounded modular
world
so we have uh we have a basis here which
is which is more skewed and longer
this i would consider to be a short
basis this is a
this is a long basis the vectors are
longer i could show you an even longer
one if uh
if i had more room on the slide so
short means you minimize the sum of all
the lengths
short well actually i mean we'll for the
purposes of the talk short we'll be
minimize the longest
vector in the basis okay so we'll
measure
the length of a basis is the the length
of its longest vector
so probably the the most commonly known
uh problem you may
may also know about it uh on lattices is
uh the shortest vector problem
it's a computational problem that asks
given an arbitrary basis b
find a non-zero lattice vector that's as
short as possible
we could relax the requirement a little
bit and ask for a gamma
approximation a gamma factor
approximation so while this dotted line
here
is the shortest vector is the shortest
vector in the lattice anything inside
the blue ball
would be an acceptable answer to the
approximation
version so typically we consider a gamma
factor that's some small polynomial in n
maybe
n squared something like that
a related problem which will be uh
which we'll actually be using for the
crypto is what i'll call decoding
and decoding on a lattice asks given a
basis b
and some target point t out in space
find a relatively close by lattice point
okay so
any solution uh in any ball any point
inside this blue ball would be a
solution to the decoding problem
actually one can show that the decoding
problem and the shortest factor problem
they're essentially the same
so we'll be using the decoding version
is also called
it is similar although they are not the
same the
closest vector problem asks for the
unique
lattice vector that's as close as
possible to the target point
what we're asking for is any point
within some fixed radius
some fixed large enough radius so in
particular we're always guaranteed that
there will be
many lattice points within that radius
but
um the any of them is a valid solution
uh if yeah and the radius will be large
enough so that we have a guarantee that
there are many points always within
uh within this radius
now in two dimensions these problems are
very easy even in ten dimensions
problems easy you could probably see it
by inspection
but uh what's interesting is that these
problems
seem to become very hard exponentially
hard in the dimension
as the dimension grows
our best algorithms take exponential
time
to solve the problems that we are
looking at and if you restrict yourself
to polynomial time
the radius that you're able to
to decode within is is something
terrible something exponentially large
so these problems appear to be very
difficult
moreover they have a very amazing
wonderful property
of essentially a worst-case and average
case equivalent
so this was the work of aitai in 96 he
showed that there is a
family a particular family of lattices
such
that if you choose a random lattice from
that family
then decoding on that lattice is as hard
as decoding on any arbitrary lattice
of a related dimension
this is a crucial property for
cryptography because we need not only
for there to be you know some hard
instances out there but we need for the
random instances that
make up our keys to be hard so the
property here is that even if you have
a vanishingly small probability of
success on a random lattice from this
family
then you can indeed solve decoding on
any
uh lattice it's really remarkable
property that's quite unique
we'll be using this this random family
uh sort of as a black box so i won't go
into any
more details about this but uh our
cryptographic schemes will
will build upon them the family is
actually quite simple to describe and a
random number is easy
easily samplable and it has all the
properties that you would like
all right so any questions uh about the
basics here
sort of i mean there's a particular
distribution over the bases
that we choose from but
within that distribution that's the
that's the family
essentially pick a basis according to
this distribution and the
the instance will be hard
all right so not only do we need hard
lattices but we also
need trap doors for them and the main
idea is that a short basis
is going to act as a trapdoor for these
hard lattices
okay that's the main idea the short
basis is something that's hard to
compute on its own
because we know we know that computing
short vectors is difficult
but if we know a short basis then it's
presumably going to give us some extra
power
working with this this lattice
so there what i see is basically two
main questions
in implementing this this main idea the
first is
how to generate the trap door and the
lattice together at the same time
right because we have to generate a
public key and a secret key
in a related way and we need the public
version of it
to be hard indeed
now in the world of factoring this is
this is trivial
essentially you just to choose two large
primes
you multiply them together you get some
modulus n and we essentially
conjecture that factoring such an n uh
is is hard for an adversary
with lattices it's not so clear how to
do this the reason why is well
you might imagine picking some short
vectors as a basis munching them up in
some way
and releasing uh some alternate version
of it the problem with this
is that you don't necessarily end up in
the hard family
so the lattice you generate may be easy
um
and it and it won't necessarily land on
the hard random family
that we would like to to use
however it's very fortunate that in a
remarkable act of foresight
italian 99 gave an algorithm that
actually selects
a lattice from the hard family together
with a short basis of it
although as far as we know this paper
was never applied
in any uh cryptographic scheme and
actually never even cited
until our work so it was very little
known
uh the basis that he generates is
relatively short although not
as short as you might like so in a
recent work we also
showed how to do the same thing while
achieving an optimally short
trapdoor basis
okay so now we know how to generate a
hard instance together with its short
basis
trapdoor the second key question
and i believe is really the more
essential one is
once we have the trapdoor how do we
actually use it securely
in a cryptographic
short basis scheme this construction for
yours
yes so uh essentially what what happens
is
uh we show a way to start with some
short vectors
to begin with and to kind of munch them
around
and end up hitting a a lattice in the
hard family
with the appropriate distribution so
it's really quite a technical work that
is difficult to describe without getting
into the details of what the hard family
looks like
although we have some basically
simplifications
making the uh generation algorithm more
modular
and a tighter analysis
the reason you'd like a shorter basis is
that it gives you tighter
concrete security you don't have to use
such large parameters
the key sizes can go down things like
this
okay so the second question is once you
have a short basis once you have this
trap door how do you use it securely in
crypto schemes
and this is of i think a very
non-trivial
uh question to answer the reason is that
there are actually proposals for using
short bases
going all the way back to 1997.
in fact they turned out to be completely
broken
because essentially the schemes leaked
information about the secret key
over time to the adversary to the point
where the adversary can actually
just reconstruct the secret key so after
releasing say several signatures
uh the adversary can can just
uh rediscover the secret key by itself
and so
i tied dwark does not use a short basis
uh at all
so there it kind of is orthogonal an
orthogonal direction
in fact i i think prior to our work
there were basically no applications of
a short basis in crypto they used for
example one short vector
in a lattice uh as the secret key
okay so this is the question we're going
to be keying upon
for the remainder of this part of the
talk in order to do so i need to
introduce to uh
one really fundamental essential concept
which is blurring a lattice so here's a
lattice in an image
if you open it up in your favorite
graphics editing
program you can there's often a special
effect called gaussian blur
that you can choose and there's a little
slider and if you move the slider up you
end up with a picture
looking something like this this kind of
corresponds to
blurring every lattice point uh with
gaussian mashing it out if you move the
slider out a little bit more it looks
like this
and as soon as you move it wide enough
the picture becomes entirely flat
formally what we can say is that the
picture becomes flat that is it's
sort of uniform over the whole space
as soon as the standard deviation of the
gaussian
exceeds the sure the length of the
shortest basis
for that lattice
okay so that gives us a lower bound on
how much
noise or how much blur we need to get to
make this uniform
this was first used in these worst case
average case connections that i talked
about
by regev and meshanchi on regev in uh
03.04
what we're going to use it we're going
to use this concept now
inside a cryptographic scheme itself
okay so here's what our here's how we'll
uh here's how we'll define our pre-image
sampleable function
first the forward direction so the
function f
is going to be specified by some hard
basis for a lattice so we generate
the lattice together with a short basis
the hard basis is what
becomes public
to evaluate the function we simply
pick a random lattice point and this is
informal
and then just perturb it by some
gaussian noise
okay and by the by the fact i showed you
in the previous slide
the outcome of this process will be
uniform over
uh the real numbers over r to the n now
in reality there is no uniform
distribution over r to the n we can make
this formal but
it's intuitively much more simple to
view it this way it's a function does a
function
choose the v or also the perturbation
both
so actually the function itself uh
there's a random input basically and the
random input specifies v
and the perturbation okay so
actually i prefer to think of it more as
a process as a randomized process rather
than a function itself
we have this randomized process which
picks out a lattice point
and adds some perturbation and the
outcome of the process is uniform
i know uniform is harder to find right
here but just intuitively
um i'm having trouble with truly uniform
right
in this sense um because
you you start at a lattice point
um even the perturbation that
is you know gaussian that goes beyond
foreign
is going to still you know have a higher
density at the end of the lattice
okay so you're exactly right that it's
not
uh it's not uniform in a
totally precise sense but it is uniform
up to negligible
statistical distance and the amount of
noise you need to add is actually quite
small
in order to make this happen
enough noise to get beyond many other
lattice points right uh you do
but actually a proof by picture right
i'll do uh
i'm not i added i don't know some amount
of noise here and and yes you're right
there's a high concentration around the
lattice here so
with this is not enough noise if i just
added i think i doubled the noise here
and suddenly it's looking pretty and i
tripled the noise and
i'm already uniform so surprisingly it
doesn't take much to uh
to get uniform so you were saying before
i mean it just takes enough noise so
that you exceed the
like minimum distance between the things
uh the
the shortest basis yeah so whatever the
sh
would that also be the minimum like if
the base
if you looked at that one picture if you
drew the distance between two points
right also translate that to the origin
right so i'll give i'll give it let me
just draw an example here
a lattice that looks like this
it has small minimum distance
this is one uh but this
would be a hundred and the shortest
basis for this lattice
has to include some vector of length 100
or at least a hundred
so in order to smooth out this lattice
we need to use
100 noise uh rather than one
i guess it surprises me that 100 is even
enough right uh it's a little bit more
than 100 times a small
factor but basically 100 yeah
it's i mean i agree it's a very
surprising fact
very useful
every point that's true yeah what what's
interesting is that actually a gaussian
itself will come effective will become
effectively uniform
uh when you move out in that way and and
this is this is very non-trivial to show
it uses some great uh
harmonic analysis and things like this
very cool
gaussian go to infinity with some small
probabilities is there always a
small probability that the signature
will break or yes i'll i'll actually
mention that uh in a moment but you're
way ahead of me yes so um
gaussians do go out to infinity however
they are highly concentrated uh within
basically a root n factor of their
standard deviation in
n dimensions so effectively a gaussian
is a ball of
uh of some radius if you cut off the
tail
okay so we're describing the forward
direction of the function here
which is to pick a random point
and add some noise enough noise to make
the whole thing uniform make the outcome
uniform
now let's consider all the possible
pre-images
of this output so this is the set of all
lattice points we could have started
from
and effectively what i claim is that all
those points have to lie within a ball
of
a relatively small radius now it's true
that
even a point way out here could produce
this t
but it's such a such a rare event that
we effectively
cut it off and say that the only
pre-images are those within this
uh within this fall okay
so if if i'm challenged
to find a pre-image of t then
effectively i have to decode t
to a relatively nearby point
something within this reasonably small
radius
this is exactly the decoding problem
that appears to be extremely hard
even on average so
we immediately get that inverting this
function finding any pre-image on t
is indeed hard
now let's look at now the set of all pre
images
of t we know there are many of them
in particular these four green points
here
let's consider now the conditional
distribution of where we could have
started
given that we ended at t okay so there's
a distribution
over these pre-image points these
lattice points and it looks something
like this
it's a gaussian but it's restricted to
lie only on the lattice
and centered at t so it's this kind of
very nice looking thing except
the support of this distribution is only
on lattice points
this object turns out to be a extremely
useful analytical tool
it's been used in the mathematical study
of lattices more recently in complexity
theory
what we're going to do is turn it into
an actual algorithmic tool
okay because what we need to do if we
want to sample a pre-image
we need to actually draw a sample from
this funny-looking uh
discrete gaussian distribution
okay everything reasonably clear so far
so the goal is that you wanted to have
constructed a primitive
which has this sample sample ability
meaning that that's right
um an adversary like a an adversary who
only has a hard basis can also generate
no so the adversary who uh only has the
hard bases can't decode t
right we don't want them to be able to
find a pre image
but given our short basis yeah we will
be able to find the pre-image
and in fact we'll sample a pre-image
from this funny funny-looking
distribution here
so strictly speaking of pre-image it's
okay to decode to any one of those
vectors
in that in that ball yes yes and how did
you determine the radius of that
okay so this ball is basically a root n
factor
times the standard deviation of the
gaussian that we started with
because a gaussian lies within
if you take a sample from a gaussian it
lies within that ball with uh
all but exponentially small probability
so effectively we kind of cut off the
tail of the gaussian and
and this doesn't affect any anything of
the argument
by the way we're learning i guess by the
financial crisis that it's dangerous to
cut off the tails of gaussians but
that's when you assume things are
gaussian when they're not we have
control over our
distributions and we can do that
gaussians are getting a bad name
nowadays and i don't think they should
it's a bit of a tangent okay
so our goal from now on is to now
implement this pre-image sample ability
implement this pre-image sampler and to
do so we need to say
we're given a short basis and a target
point t
and we want to sample from this this
funny looking object efficiently
okay seems uh seems challenging
what i want to stress is that
this distribution here is oblivious to
our short basis
it doesn't know what short basis we're
going to use it's just a gaussian and it
exists independent of any particular
basis
all we know is that it's deviation is
related to the length of the basis but
nothing more
so we need to use our basis to sample
from an object
from a distribution that
has no knowledge of our basis it seems
like a difficult
task but in fact the algorithm itself is
extremely simple
basically what we do is add a randomized
twist to
this classical algorithm of babai from
which is uh pretty much what you might
come up with if you had the afternoon to
think about it
so this pla this algorithm is called the
nearest plane algorithm and it works as
follows
we have a target point t we want to
decode and a short basis
what we do is imagine partitioning the
lattice into hyperplanes
where each hyperplane contains uh
a different integer multiple of s2 but
we'll work from the back
from the back forward so this is uh zero
times s2 is the plane with 1 times s2
2 times s2 and so forth so we know the
part the
lattice partitions in this way
and the baby's nearest plane algorithm
would simply
round off t to the nearest plane as the
name suggests
what we'll do is not deterministically
round off to the nearest plane
but actually choose a plane at random
according to an appropriate distribution
so maybe we don't go to the nearest but
we round off
to this one randomized round to this one
instead
and we project t down to the hyperplane
and then just iterate in one lower
dimension
okay so then we might random randomly
round off to the nearest point
in the subplane if we run this algorithm
a different time maybe we round off here
and round off that way
what's i think extremely interesting and
surprising is that this algorithm
does indeed sample from this
distribution
and it loses it doesn't care which
basis you start with as long as you have
the basis of bounded length
okay so to prove this is
somewhat technical as you might imagine
but the idea behind the proof
is that if we look at the ideal thing
that we really want to sample from let's
look at the probability mass on every
plane
yes
statistic does not depend on the tractor
base why is it trapped or why can't i
use any bases to
good okay so the key is uh
this condition up here the standard
deviation that we sample from
has to exceed the length of the uh
longest element
so if i have a basis which is very bad i
won't be able to sample from a tight
tight gaussian that's that's a that's
the key difference but if i have a basis
which is
quite short i can sample from a gaussian
that's very concentrated
and that's the difference between having
a bad basis and having a good basis
okay so i i won't i won't say much about
the proof other than the fact that
essentially the output of this algorithm
is oblivious
to the actual basis that was used uh in
to to run the algorithm which i think is
somewhat surprising
so that also means that the tableau is
generally not unique
that's correct yes there are many there
are many equivalent tracks
satisfying that inequalities exactly
exactly any basis
of short enough basis gives you the same
power
essentially
so nine questions so why can't you use
um
decoding algorithms in this context what
am i missing here
um so like lattice decoding algorithms
so linear codes basically just
determined by a basis
right so i mean you've got this
continuous aspect here where you've
perturbed it
right so the first answer is that uh
decoding algorithms for codes typically
only work
when you're within some bounded radius
of the code so you have to be within a
close distance to the code in order for
it to work
if you're outside of that the output is
is undefined
we need this to work on an arbitrary
point in
in the reals moreover we need it we need
the output
of the of the algorithm to be randomized
i mean
it's essential for security that we are
sampling a random element
according to this distribution and not
that we're just finding some close by
uh lattice point uh and and
if if we were to be deterministic here
then
that would uh be a very big security
problem
in your procedure for providing um the
pre-images yes yes so
it has it's very crucial it has to be
randomized and it has to
to draw from from this distribution yeah
but i meant for the adversary
who's trying to say okay yeah so the
adversary uh
because it has a bad basis essentially
the decoding problem is
is very difficult because if it tries to
run this if it tries to run say this
algorithm
it's going to end up with a point the
lattice point very very far away
from the target and and that's just
because when you get down to rounding
um the points are going to be very far
spread
within these hyper planes and so you're
taking huge jumps at each step
and it takes you too far away
during the algorithm to find the lattice
point
just finding a nearby lattice point and
then randomizing
right because this is actually
what the signer does so this is not a
thought experiment or anything like that
but the signing algorithm has to
has to draw from this particular
distribution
you might imagine other ways of trying
to get this but you really need to
to draw from this precise distribution
uh otherwise
you start leaking information about your
basis so
it's really quite crucial you do it
exactly this way
and that's illustrated actually by the
breaks of the prior
prior proposals the ggh scheme and the
andrew
scheme that we have
all right so i believe
yes okay let me just mention a few other
applications cryptographic applications
we'll
bubble up to the top here and get out of
the technical details
um so another
application of uh these short basis is
something called
identity-based encryption and
essentially the idea here
goes back to shamir from 1984 and he
said what if you didn't have to have a
public key there's all these
certification problems with public keys
what if your name was your public key
someone wants to encrypt a message to
you all they need to know is your name
and maybe one key for your entire
microsoft organization
so it was about 17 years before this was
actually possible
possible to do something like this by
the scheme of bonee and franklin
and somewhat surprisingly we can now do
it based on lattices
as well so this is a very powerful
primitive
and it has lots of applications
uh further work we showed
some zero knowledge proof systems
that also use the short basis in a
critical way
and this can be used for for public key
certification
identification protocols lots of things
like that
we also gave a protocol called oblivious
transfer which is a fundamental object
in
multi-party computation and it has the
very
interesting property that it's what's
called universally composable
it means you can run it in the context
of many other algorithms you can run it
in parallel concurrently with
anything on the network and it remains
secure and moreover
the protocol is extremely efficient it's
round optimal it's one message from the
sender to the
uh from the receiver to the sender and
then one message back
so it's very uh efficient
and we give a general framework actually
that works for a variety under a variety
of different assumptions
and lattices are among those
a fourth application is uh chosen
ciphertext security so
here the use of the short basis is
really essential for achieving
uh this strong gold gold standard notion
of uh
security for encryption for example your
question about it dwork when they have
just one
short vector involved it's not clear at
all how you can get chosen ciphertext
security with that kind of scheme
surprisingly with
with a short basis you can you can do it
quite naturally actually
and i think there's more to come more
applications of this to come as well
okay so i'll finish off with a couple
lines of related work
and some problems i'd like to look at in
the future so
one line is is using some special
objects
special classes of lattice is called
cyclic
or ideal lattices these are lattices
that have some extra symmetries
geometric symmetries or algebraic
symmetries in them and the idea is that
we can build truly practical schemes
that have
relatively small key sizes and are
really really fast
so this is the foundation these ideas
are the foundation of
our candidate submission to the
sha-3 competition that's being run by
nist right now which
our function is called swift the extra f
is to make it a fast fourier transform
which is the core operation involved in
evaluating the function
and ffts are really nice because you can
run them
in parallel there are specialized
circuits for them and we can implement
them really fast
even on standard commodity processors
so really really fast means if you give
us all the
power of uh your you know your intel
core duo or whatever uh our throughput
is comparable to
sha say 256 sha 512. it's within a
couple
couple factors factor of two to three
and that's not even using multiple cores
so that's on one core
and i think what's what's promising
about this approach is that
it's going to scale up very nicely to
the future because parallelism is going
to become more and more
available to us we now have graphics
cards that you know
have so much parallelism on them we
don't know what to do with it
uh and you can and they're they are fft
machines
so uh i i think this is this is a
promising approach
this parallelism aspect
actually over a finite field so more
accurately would be the what's
sometimes called the number theoretic
transform we you can actually do it over
either so if your hardware works for
for the complex numbers it's fine you
can run it over the complex but
the function is defined over a field
and the number and the fft can be done
over that finite field
if to keep everything discreet
what's the property of a cyclic or an
ideal lattice that's being used
so the property is that uh
okay so i'll say what a cyclic lattice
is
it's a lettuce where every point
uh if you have a point in the lattice
then you can
rotate its coordinates so you can bring
the first coordinate to the end and
push everything forward and that point
will also be in the lattice so there's
this closure property
and of course you can rotate as many
times as you want and it
remains in the lattice so this kind of
seemingly
simple symmetry has some really deep
connections to algebraic number theory
it turns out so
getting into number fields and and rings
of integers and all kinds of great
great stuff there so some work in
progress is to take the
take the ideas that are behind the hash
function and do things like
encryption and signatures as well
with comparable levels of efficiency
the dream would be to get public key
crypto that can run
as fast or almost as fast as
symmetric key crypto does now or hash
functions do now
that would be that's the long term
vision
so it's actually the same as being like
having a normal basis uh let's see a
normal base
i don't i don't know what a normal basis
is this
is like um like one all the powers of an
algebraic energy like one alpha alpha
squared
oh okay so a power basis
uh yes it's similar it's similar to that
in fact that's where the
the connections start to to come about
um you don't have to have a power basis
so so getting into ideals and things
like that
um we can talk about it maybe more
offline but
similar similar kinds of closure
properties like that
and and the the benefit here is that the
lattice can be represented
in a much more compact form so the keys
are smaller
and the manipulations can now be doing
ffts
uh rather than generic inner products
and and
slower operations like that so what the
hard problem is still
what finding an alpha i mean finding a
short basis uh yes the hard problem is
to find a short vector
in the special class of lattices now so
so it's
potentially this extra structure may
potentially make the problems easier
although
nobody is as far as i'm aware has found
any way to exploit that what dimension
do you use
the dimension here so there's no
clear answer there's a trade-off between
the dimension and the field size
that you can that you can make in
practice swift has dimension
64 and a field size of 257
so the overall group is of size 257 to
the 64 which is i think
around uh 10 24 or something
or no more 4096 i don't know i can't
but sorry
uh so so it's two to the eighth
yeah and a little bit extra uh okay yes
yeah so it sounds like it's equivalent
to like um
if you use just ll for finding algebraic
dependence
right you can usually find
i mean 64 sounds load oh so the
dimension the dimension of the
underlying lattice is not actually 64.
um so there are some complications
regarding what what does the actual
uh reduction give you
and what are the actual best algorithms
known and the reduction is often looser
than
the best attack so in order to be
practical we designed swift to defeat
all the known attacks
and that makes you trade off the
dimension and the field size
and and things like this so uh
so it's not really a dimension of 64 as
it's a
larger uh thing in practice but
there are lots of lots of detailed you
know
fiddling with exact security parameters
and things like that involved
just a related question so so what
happens if you use lll in the setting of
your more general settings
right so what happens if you run lll is
you can get
vectors in the lattice which are
somewhat short but they're really
they're really far too long to be of any
use
so you you ll basically gives you this
exponentially bad
approximation to uh to a short vector to
the shortest vector
so you can ll actually turns out to be
not a very promising avenue of attack
there are other more combinatorial
attacks that actually do even better
but even those are are far too weak to
uh
to break the schemes and in the context
of this applications you were listing
before this slide what would the n be
typically what would the dimension be
uh let's see so in these
it would have to be at least in the high
hundreds i think
um for to get a meaningful security
proof you know end-to-end
security proof uh again i'll say in in
practice what happens is the
the proof is often looser than what
appears to be the true hardness of the
problem
so what we do is we typically prove the
scheme is secure in an asymptotic sense
and then we start to look at okay what
are the concrete
uh dimensions needed to defeat
the best attacks available and they're
basically
kind of two classes of attacks and
if we we beat them both handily then we
say okay this is
these are reasonable security levels uh
reasonable key sizes
um another direction is to just define
and construct more
uh rich crypto schemes so crypto schemes
that have useful properties
allow us to do things that we want to do
for example in a work
with brent waters from last stock we
defined and constructed some
objects called lossy trapdoor functions
which have a ton of applications and
many more seem to be coming down the
line
recently we also did a
very simple and efficient construction
of what's called circular secure
encryption
which is often needed in things like
formal models
proving crypto secure and formal models
it's also used in uh
credential systems and and things like
this so this is a nice
a nice primitive to have and in progress
i have some work on
getting even more expressive
expressiveness to the identity based
uh schemes that we constructed before
circular secure means you can encrypt
your own secret key
under your under the under the
corresponding public key
and uh the question is is this actually
is it secure to do this
so i get in in things like disk
encryption products
it often happens that the secret key uh
ends up on disk and then gets encrypted
in it with itself
and uh this can cause some problems none
of the security proofs don't in general
go through
and you can devise kind of pathological
schemes that actually break if you do
such a thing
so we'd like to have some kind of
guarantee that it's safe
to do things like this and it can be
generalized through cycles of
key encryptions among many different
parties that are unrelated
things like that
i'm also interested in the basic
complexity theoretic foundations of
lattices
i've given some uh have some works on
stronger connections between the worst
case and average case hardness
of lattice problems and i think more
generally it's it's interesting to look
at
things like learning algorithms hardness
amplification extractors things like
that
which have been developed for discrete
domains uh and and to extend or see
which of these things make sense and
which can be done over
continuous domains as well
uh looking to the future some big kind
of very vague problems
i don't even know how to express
necessarily
there are basically two kinds of
approaches to solving lattice problems
and they
don't seem to be compatible at all
they're kind of incomparable
i think there should be some unified way
that gets the best of both of those
so i'd be interested in looking at that
and investigating what's the true
complexity of
of these lattice problems
what's the nature what are the
limitations of quantum attacks do we
have a good reason to
think that quantum can't break
lattice-based schemes
we don't have algorithms but quantum's
very misunderstood and
understood so uh this is a this is a
very important
direction to go and i think developing
further connections between
standard number theory problems that we
use in in crypto and these lattice
problems
would be very interesting it would be
excellent to have a proof that
says factoring is
uh no harder than solving the lattice
problems that we rely on that would mean
that
these lattice-based schemes are at least
secure as factoring based schemes we
don't
have any connection right now so we
don't know whether one is strictly
better
than the other and it would be nice to
get some kind of ordering
among them that's all
thank you
so it seems like if an attacker can get
you to
hash the same i sent you the signature
for the same message
multiple times yes they've learned
something about the distribution yes
this is
actually a very good point that i uh
completely slid under the rug so
as i described the scheme maybe i'll go
back to it
okay gotta go back a ways but that's
okay
we'll get there almost okay
so yes the question is what happens if
you
ask the signer to sign the same message
twice
presumably what they'll do is well
they'll hash the message
they'll get the same y in both cases
it's a deterministic
function look at the same y and then
they'll
run the pre-image sampler and they'll
get probably two different
pre-images in both cases and is this a
problem yes it's
it'd be a huge problem if they if they
got this so what we do
uh actually in the system is add some
randomization to the uh message
so if you tack some random salt onto the
message and send the salt along
with uh with things then what happens is
you get a different y every time
even if you sign the same message so
that's one one way of doing it
um and and in that case we can you know
prove
that it's that it's really secure
the signer chooses the salt yep and
sends it along with with the signature
so only a few bits are needed
another solution is to kind of keep
state
so the signer checks have i signed this
message before if so it releases the
same signature
not so useful but uh the state can
actually be removed using
uh something called a pseudorandom
function as well so if you if you don't
like salt uh you can use a pseudorandom
function
and that ensures that you're always
giving out the same signature on the
same message
yeah it's a very uh important
aspect in the implementation
if you want the standard security
parameters that nist and nsa propose
how many bits do you need in this in the
public key in the private key in the
randomness you use for a signature
right um so the answer is it depends if
you're using these general
these general lattices i think the keys
the key sizes and so forth are probably
too large for
for prime time right now
that's why we're looking at cyclic and
ideal lattices because they bring the
key sizes down dramatically
they bring the uh the signature sizes
down and
kind of all aspects of the scheme get
smaller and more compact
what do you hope to get at the end so at
the end of the day i don't think we'll
be getting
keys that are one kilobit
like they are for rsa i think that's
probably too much to hope for
i think would it be a megabit i think i
think under that i think probably in the
tens of kilobits
is a reasonable thing maybe even down
below 10
10 kilobits for things like public key
encryption
now for our for our nist uh hash
function submission
the key is some um
it's some fixed key so it's hardwired
into the code
and uh it's not big it's not big it's uh
and how much randomness
do you need per signature how many bits
of random to run this algorithm yes
signature right right it needs
randomness yes
uh there's a lower bound of at least uh
n
bits of randomness
how many bits of random that does cost
me uh let's see
so if you really want to optimize the
randomness you're going to be needing
around
a little more than linear so n to the
one plus epsilon bits of randomness
where n is the dimension
of the thing now the dim the real
dimension in the crypto scheme
could be something like around a
thousand or more
so the answer is probably a couple
kilobits of randomness
the answer is vice versa
and and true or ntru is uh
is actually based on a lot of the ideas
behind cyclic lattices
and that's kind of what inspired the the
theoretical work
andrew lacks any security proofs
at all and it's been broken several
times
the different schemes of entry have been
broken several times for example
uh this is the um
called entrusine so it's the entro it's
a signature variant of entrue
uh it was broken by this attack of uh
wynn and regev
in 2006 there are some additional
countermeasures that are
proposed here we broke those uh in
a recent work that we've submitted so
the problem and the problems with entrue
is that they don't have really uh
any rigorous security analysis
everything's pretty heuristic
uh and and for that reason i think
things have broken a lot
been been broken a lot over time and
have to keep moving the goal posts
so i really think this is an example
where
lettuces are so subtle that we really
should be using provable security
techniques to make sure that our
schemes are really rock solid
you know and don't have design flaws in
them
so their design doesn't reduce to a
problem like
shortest basis probably right right yeah
there's no security reduction or
security proofs involved
there are sort of heuristic assumptions
about this particular family of lattices
is hard and and concrete
values but uh no
no proofs basically of any security
so i know the underlying design is
drastically different
right but at a very high level this
approach
feels to me a lot like knapsack
there's a secret specialized basis
which you can do stuff with is you
transform that
exactly some way to a random
hard basis right that other people use
publicly
right and
so does that keep me up at night is the
question yeah because knapsacks have
failed over and over
right now the re this is the this is the
reason why knapsacks have failed
the reason is they generate some
they start with some you know special
basis or something and then they they
munch it up and end up with
some kind of lattice or knapsack kind of
problem
the issue with this is that because of
the way they started out and
because of the way it gets generated
this this resulting problem
has some hidden structure in it the
structure is still there
and that's what gets that's what gets
used as a lever to break these old
knapsack problems
the the very nice thing here is that
we're generating our instance from the
truly hard random family where we have a
security proof
that this instance is hard and it's
drawn uniformly from the hard family and
yet we still are able to embed
a secret basis into it a short secret
basis into it so
i mean i really want to stress that this
is a crucial aspect of
of how the schemes get used if you do
something more heuristic
you may be leaving yourself open to some
hidden structure that can be exploited
and this these methods are end up with a
structureless
key within
this somewhat structured hard set yes
yes
okay